right now we have breaking news from the
Middle East Britain said overnight that
three Iranian boats tried to intercept a
British oil tanker the confrontation
took place in the Strait of Hormuz a
vital shipping lane at the center of
current tensions with Iran Charlie
d'Agata who's reported extensively from
the region is following developments
from London Charlie what happened
well British military officials
confirmed to us this morning that
Iranian boats attempted to impede that
British tanker overnight before Navy
escort issued verbal warnings to get out
of the way British Navy officials tell
CBS News this warship the HMS Montrose
wedged itself between the cargo ship and
three Iranian paramilitary vessels
demanding safe passage of this cargo
ship the British heritage registered to
British Petroleum the Iranian boats
backed off the scrapped on the high seas
comes a week to the day since British
commandos seized an Iranian super tanker
off the coast of Gibraltar over
allegations it was breaking sanctions by
transporting oil to Syria accusations
denied by Iran mumbling did you see on
me just yesterday Iranian president
Hassan rouhani warned there would be
consequences and that the British were
sick to send frigates to escort their
ships tensions were already running high
after a series of attacks on tankers in
recent weeks blamed on Iran when we were
last there US Navy gunboats took us to
see up close the damaged Navy
investigators told us caused by the kind
of limpet mines used by Iran's
Revolutionary Guard this despite a
significant u.s. military buildup in the
region including the USS abraham lincoln
strike carrier group and b-52 bombers
Iran's Revolutionary Guard is denying
that it confronted any alien vessels
especially British they said that if
they had received the order to seize his
ship they would have done so immediately
Michelle Charlie d'Agata in London thank
you